it is one of the most copied works of
literature for effectively a thousand
years so it's a it's a book that
essentially let's put it this way that
anyone who could read for the better
part of a thousand years in the west was
reading boethus it's it's unbelievably
influential and that with his other
translations make their way into the
Middle Ages and so the the metaphor I
like to use it's like you know the
flowers have have died we we know we
heard Ian hery Ali recently say the West
is a cut flower it's like the flowers
have died but these books are seeds
these books are seeds of the ideas and
it's as if he cast them forward into the
future so that hundreds of years after
his death those seeds would grow again
into you might say the beautiful garden
of of of Western you know medieval
culture this is Jonathan Pedro welcome
to the symbolic
[Applause]
world so everyone it is a pleasure to
finally have Stephen Blackwood on my
channel uh as you know uh Stephen
Stephen is the president and founder of
rosson college he was also one of my uh
he was my neighbor at The Exodus seminar
you know sitting next to me bringing us
back to this story you know
expressing his wisdom with with so much
tact uh you know he's become a friend
and someone that I respect very much and
so I'm happy to have him on and we're
going to talk about uh boethus we're
going to enter into boethius's
consolation of philosophy Stephen wrote
a wonderful book uh called the
consolation of boethus as poetic liturgy
and I mean I read this I was amazed at
some of the things he was bringing up
you know I'm not someone who's that good
at poetry but that I could just see when
I was reading his text that he was so
close to the way I see the world and to
the things that I care about and so I'm
excited for him to be able to expound
that for us today so Stephen thanks for
coming on thanks for having me Jonathan
yeah so tell me a start off like what it
is that attracted you first of all to to
boas's text maybe how people most people
will know boas but maybe you know give a
brief introduction of of who he is what
it is was going on around him and why he
wrote his
consolation well I think that uh well
bu's been a big inspiration for me for
for for many years and uh you know just
in a really quick sketch the you we're
talking about the he's born in the late
fifth century ad so sort of right around
the fall of Rome
475 or or so and then he uh he lives for
about 50 years and he's born into a to a
wealthy uh should actually adopted into
a wealthy sort of very Patrician family
and he's he gets the the best education
you can get probably in you in Athens or
Alexandria he learns Greek uh does all
of the studies all of the forms of
knowledge that were were important you
know music and and and Mathematics
astronomy you know rhetoric logic all of
those all of those things
philosophy and uh he rises to the very s
very highest Heights of the of the Roman
Empire this is after the fall of Rome
now right so so rather than an emperor
there's a kind of foreign King theodoric
uh but it's it's it's it's kind of as if
you had you know at one of our modern
States everything was functioning except
a foreign King had come in over the top
and so it's it's actually much more
coherent than people might might think
so he rises to the very you know the
Senate is still there and and so on he
he becomes the uh the master of offices
the mistro vorum uh he becomes a Consul
and he says the happiest day of his his
his his life is that uh his is the day
his two sons both become consuls and the
reason I I share this is because he's at
the very sort of tiptop of of Education
of political uh influence of wealth of
of of of sophistication he's a he's a
he's a poet he's a mathematician he's an
inventor he's he's really just at the
very top of of his game and and and what
what what
brius uh sees is that Rome which had for
so long relied upon you might say Greek
intellectual
infrastructure and this is this is not a
a wild claim I mean the the the all of
the Romans the educated Romans were
themselves speaking Greek for hundreds
of years and being educated in Greece
and actually forging their their their
literature according to Greek models and
their architecture and all of that they
UND they understood this themselves very
very self-consciously um but Greek is
being lost and and and so buus sets
himself to task to translate
all of these kind of seminal texts of
Greek into Latin latinize this this
super structure of of of of of
wisdom and uh he he translates Works in
mathematics and and logic and and and
music and so on and these are
effectively kind of latinization you
know making available you know pretty
much someone else's work into a form
it's a translation or a you know a
making available in a new form but Lar
into translation and then dis absolute
disaster strikes he is accused of
treason and thrown in prison
and a year later
uh he is according to contempor the
Contemporary accounts we have he's Haled
to prison and uh uh brutally tortured
and
executed and uh that's the end of buthus
that's the end of this man who had hoped
let's say say to had the dream in some
sense I think you can say the dream of
restoring the intellectual foundations
of his of his beloved sort of you know
City and and of all of
Rome uh ends in in in the worst sort of
in a sense death you can can
imagine except of course that's not the
end of buus while he is in prison he
writ a book that is not contradict with
everything he's written but at the same
time totally different these texts on
you know the translation of nomus and so
on they're very dry I mean you know you
should read them if you're interested
but they're very hard to get through
they're very dry they're very logic
chopping they're all about ratios and
the music and so on that was that was an
important text for almost 2,000
years and but you know they're they're a
slog let's put it that way and and in
prison while he's in prison he writes
one of the most astonishing works of
literature that I think has ever ever
ever been written and and in this it's
like he
puts in a certain sense he puts all of
his fine-tuned learning down and he goes
right to the heart of the question but
of course he's not putting it down he's
putting it into a new form these years
of study and in this and in this book he
uh this is a a work of consolation this
is a a book in which very raw in which a
woman who's a personification of
philosophy comes to comfort a man a
prisoner a man who's been bereft of
taken away everything that he had his
his wealth his family his position his
reputation everything he's got nothing
left and there he is in his PR so it's
you know buus played by himself you
might say in this in this amazing
literary drama and and this this this
woman named philosophy comes to comfort
him and to restore him to his inner
self-possession to his his his his
knowledge and possession of himself
and that's the you know we may perhaps
we'll have a talk a bit about the the
book but but but in terms of the
biography uh what's amazing is that uh
uh you know this book that is in a way
so different from his other works uh
just the literary power the the gripping
character of this I I I say that uh uh
this is this is one of those books that
you can give to someone who's in an
enormously difficult situation whether
it's you know cancer or or terminal
disease or or loss or or or you know
some kind of form or pain or
indecipherable you know thing in their
lives uh and it and it speaks directly
to that because that's where it starts
that's the that's the problem this book
is written about and we don't we
actually don't know uh really how this
book got out into circulation and
somehow got out of the the the the
prison there's there's so far as I know
there's little to no record of it for
like 200 years and so imagine you here
this this you know this long Arc it's so
important to remember these things you
know the long Arc of of of of time of
culture of civilization of the Soul uh
he this man who I think had hoped in his
own lifetime that these works that he
was translating would help to restore
Rome he did not know Rome was really
effectively over you know a few decades
after his death it's you know it's a
kind of Backwater goes from a million uh
inhabitants or so at it at its height to
essentially you know 30,000 it's like a
swampy Backwater during the the the the
Carol engine into the Middle Ages but
what I want to leave you leave this this
uh moment of his biography with is this
book somehow gets out and after a couple
hundred hundred years it it really gets
out and it's the it's translated in
English by King Alfred we were talking
about that um
earlier and uh but in Latin it is it is
one of the most copied works of
literature for effectively A Thousand
Years so it's a it's a book that
essentially let's put it this way that
anyone who could read for the better
part of a thousand years in the west was
reading beus it's it's unbelievably
influential and that with his other
translations make their way into the
Middle Ages and so the the metaphor I
like to use it's like you know the
flowers have have died we we know we
heard Ian hery Ali recently say the West
is a cut flower it's like the flowers
have died but these books are seeds
these books are seeds of the ideas and
it's as if he cast them forward into the
future so that hundreds of years after
his death those seeds would grow again
into you might say the beautiful garden
of of of Western you know medieval
culture yeah and so there's a sense in
which buthus though he he thought I
think that well he had no doubt hopes as
we all do that his work would bear some
fruit in his lifetime uh you he had a a
terrible death and yet in the long span
of time time and perhaps you could say
Pro Providence uh that which he had
given his life to Bears enormous fruit
hundreds of years uh after his death and
so I've often thought about this that
you know from buthus we see it's not up
to us What Becomes of our work it's only
up to us to do to undertake it as
Faithfully as we can yeah and I think
you're some of some of the ideas that
you brought about are important to
emphasize which is
that the boethius's work you know became
a model for literature in the Middle
Ages became a model for poetry became a
model you know and did ultimately more
to synthesize the ancient Greek thinking
and Carry It Forward than like you said
his other kind of copying of of ancient
text and so there's a strange innovation
in the text itself but it is also a kind
of gathering together in crisis so his
personal crisis his suffering and the
you know the things that he had to go
through become like a microcosm of what
is happening to the West at that moment
you with all the barbarians coming in
and and this kind of moment of
uncertainty and chaos and in this in
that strange way like you said the book
itself becomes a little Arc that carries
all this thinking in a very compressed
form with all its different meters and
its different approach to poetry into
the flowering of the of the High Middle
Ages you could say and becomes a model
for that um I want to invite you all to
the very first symbolic World Summit
over 3 days we will finally meet in real
time in real space and everyone from
this little corner of the internet will
be there to explore the theme of
reclaiming the cosmic image of course I
will be speaking but there will also be
Martin Shaw who is an amazing
mythographer father Steven D young of
Lord of spirit Fame there will be
Richard Roland from the universal
history series veser Stamper Nicholas
kotar and Neil de gr that you've all
seen on my channel here and there for
entertainment we have everyone's
favorite apocalyptic band The One and
Only dirt po Robins this event will be
the chance of a lifetime to capture and
embrace our current moment so join us
from February 29th to March 2nd 2024 in
Tarpon spings Florida visit the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information
and I will see you
there
[Music]
and it's also important it's hard for
people to think that because so many
people think that the Middle Ages are
just a dark period you know they don't
understand to what extent poetry and and
music and you know meter was important
especially in what we call the high
Middle Ages in the west into the weird
weirdly too into the world that into the
Barbarian world that had taken over his
Rome right so the influence of his work
will made itself will make it itself
known in France and England in all of
these Barbarian lands that are now kind
of Reviving the Roman the Roman world so
it really
is an astounding story of how of what of
what he was able to do in his
suffering yeah yeah and it's a very
important point you make about the way
he's Gathering up the wisdom of the past
and um you know he's he's
he's you know today we sort of you know
have this idea that you know try and say
something original and and and and new
and you know for buus you know he was I
think you know he thought the highest
thing that you know in a way the highest
and best would be to to to to share the
greatest uh uh you might say the wisdom
of the past in a way that could be heard
and and heard and new and so he he he is
writing as if you might say it's his
work is synthesizing and bringing
together um without saying he's doing
that I'm not saying he think oh here I
have I've got all the answers right here
no he's he's he's but what he's actually
doing is is take looking back to Plato
and Aristotle and to the stoics and and
the neoplatonist and all the poetic
tradition to Homer uh and uh and indeed
I I I would argue to the to to his
experience of of Christianity and
bringing all of this up in a form that
uh that he thinks is fundamental so it
can speak to his time interestingly uh I
mentioned Christianity we we know we the
Christian he wrote texts on on the
Trinity and so on there's no mention of
Christianity or of Christ or anything
like that in the consolation it's a
really interesting uh kind of question
or challenge or history for for many
scholars um uh and my I'll simply say
that my my sense of that is that what
he's doing is is sharing uh the wisdom
as he understands it in a universal form
and we could talk about you know what
the logos is and and what he might have
understood uh uh about the relationship
between the let's call it the Pagan and
uh Christian trai Traditions or the old
Pagan philosophical tradition and and
the Christian uh religion is a very very
interesting uh question but
fundamentally he's putting things in a
language of universality and that's one
of the reasons I think he's such an
important voice today uh because amidst
our our our our our fragments are
alienated sort of dysfunctional uh dis
disagreements uh often you know very
shallow uh he he he offers I think a
voice that goes right to the heart of
very fundamental uh human questions yeah
and I I think the way that I also
understand his work is something like
the maintaining of a secular space in
within Christianity that
is you know and you can see it again
play in terms of microcosms which is
that he's expressing the continu ation
of the Pagan world the neoplatonic world
the the Greek world into this burgeoning
Christian World he's expressing that as
a possible you know image of what of
what is good and what is what is in the
future and then you could say that not
surprisingly that his aesthetic or his
vision gets taken up by the secular
world in in the the Virgin and Christian
reality which is why the Kings you know
supposedly Queen Elizabeth also like
loved boethus and King Alfred and these
secular figures would look to boethus
because they were playing in some ways a
secular role within the Christian Vision
they were they were not directly related
you know although they did go to church
they were Christians they were somewhat
of a remove for that somewhat like a
narx of the church um and I think that
that's one of the powerful things about
Christianity that people forget in are
kind of postan age which is that is the
way the Christianity laid itself out as
being both you know having the highest
mystery in these theological uh texts
and these mystical hymns but then also
being able to entertain you know the
works of soc The Works of Aristotle The
Works of Plato The Works of the Greeks
and a vision of poetry even preserving
the dramatic text preserving the the the
works of literature that were produced
in the in the ancient world as a kind of
you could say narx to Christianity a
place where we can explore these ideas
without explicitly saying always having
a religious uh well and there's just two
quick points to add to that and the
first is that uh you know people today
forget that
uh the the Greeks thought there were
entirely rational you know might say
philosophical arguments uh you they talk
about the highest good or or God uh or
about the practices that enable you to
approach or understand or come as close
as you can to understanding those things
those are those are completely rational
philosophically divised
derive principles so it's not as if you
know you've got this I don't know some
sort of cold philosophy in the one hand
and then in the the other hand with
these kind of Simply irrational or
mystical practices I mean it's the most
ra for the Greeks it's the most rational
thing in the world you might say to to
to try to understand uh uh uh that which
you do not understand that which is
beyond you uh and to be adequate somehow
to that understanding we could talk
about intellectual humility we could
talk about you know so this this what
I'm suggesting is that is that in in in
in the consolation for example there
comes a moment in right in the middle of
the book in the middle of the argument
where philosophy system you know you
know the problem with with our thinking
our kind of rational thinking is it
divides things up and you know divides
up that which is which we most seek
which is one and whole and unified might
say the highest good it divides it up in
such a way that that that that it can't
sat it can't satisfy precisely because
it's dividing it up and we could talk
about you know the implication of that
argument but what what she says is is
that so what do we need to do like
what's the answer to that problem that's
a big problem and it's a problem we all
face day by day right which is that you
know the way in which all of your
efforts can outstrip can somehow divide
up or be inadequate to the to the thing
that you seek which is kind of a a
unified self-possession and so uh and
she says well and what do you think we
should do and he says well we should
seek the father of all things and so
what you really see in this fulcrum of
the argument is that they're turning
upward you might say to that which is
the source of rational understanding but
in a unified form and they're seeking
they're seeking that source for help to
bridge that divide and so all I want to
say is that you we talk about the the
the the religious element here what I
what I want to say is there is a Phil
there's a there's such a thing as a
philosophical religion in which you are
you you adopting habits and practices
that you know are necessary it doesn't
take some add-ons some big leap or
anything like that it's it this is like
this is a fund something you can do on a
fundamentally rational basis and the
other point I would make just very
quickly is that is that it's not it's
also that the the the the the
inheritance of these uh chist these
these platonic and artian the neoplus
and so on the Greek the Greeks broadly
speaking it's not uh just that they were
kind of you sort of useful in the
background they're absolutely vital to
the whole history of Christian theology
to understand itself I mean you know the
Bible's written you know the New
Testament is written in Greek the Creeds
are written in Greek and there's a
reason for that and so you might say
they're they're they're interpreting and
understand I'm not saying that it's
there that that Christianity can be
reduced to the ancient Greeks but what I
am saying is that we we don't as a as a
fact get our understanding of what
Christianity is about in the west
outside of the the mediation uh of uh of
the intellectual structures that enabled
that to be understood and and in a sense
it's not just that this goes so far and
then this picks up it it's there's a
sense in which those intellectual
structures themselves are transformed by
their engagement with the Christian
Revelation so it works both ways yeah I
think that's a that's a great point I
was you know because obviously you know
you send me this book your your book and
I was reading it and I thought well I
have to reread the consolation I hadn't
read it in maybe 15 years or something
and I was so struck by that part of the
book itself I felt like I was falling
right into the problem of emergence the
the question of complexity that we're
dealing with today and and I realized to
what extent you know how deeply boreus
had perceived it and what you know and
you can see that this type of thinking
you know the relationship between the
many and the one and the the kind of
jump into Intuition or this jump into
something which transcends multiplicity
you know was was so deeply understood
and now it's become a mystery to us
because we we've had a few centuries of
of kind of rationalistic scientism that
is running out now and and people are
realizing that again but definitely
revisiting those chapters in the
constellation is is worth it for people
who are thinking about the problem of
complexity you know even in technical
terms right now um so maybe we can just
quickly well not quickly but you know
yeah go into the argument of the of the
book itself before we fall into the
rhythms that's the thing that I I really
want to get into but maybe we can help
people understand a little bit what the
argument of the book you know buus is is
basically lost all the things that
thinks or that most people think has are
valuable to life that are what make you
what make life valuable and then
consolation is trying to help him see
through that uh and so maybe you can p
take people through the kind of basic
argument of the book and and what he's
trying to help what philosophy is trying
to help breus
understand I i' I'd love I'd love to and
tell me if I'm going too slow I try and
do this as quickly as I can you know
it's like sorry it's like reduce the one
of these fuls of Western Civilization to
a few sentences please at least you know
no more than so many words well well let
me just first uh take take the take it
uh take the chance if I if I can uh some
of your your listeners might be
interested in I suspect and if they
haven't already read read the
constellation of philosophy and and if
they're looking for uh to read it in in
English uh the the one that I I most
like is this one this little Little Red
Book it's called the Lo from the lobe
Library L EB it's published by Harvard
just a little about as big is your hand
and it's got the Latin and the English
uh both together and so you can look
back and forth but it's a nice little
volume have on the Shelf uh there's
something lurgical there's something
just very beautiful about the material
materiality of a book I can't read books
uh uh uh on a Kindle or something myself
very successfully and so I I like to
recommend this just because I think it's
a beautiful experience to have this book
uh in your hand but the the basic
argument is this is that it
starts very very powerfully uh with we
uh with a poem and it's a Woe Is Me poem
Oh you know this all this has happened
and you know I'm I'm I wish I could die
uh you know but I can't you know but you
know I call for death and he doesn't
come and it's just it's very wo is me
poem it's not and and uh uh and then the
book says I as I was writing as these
verses were being dictated to me by the
muses and the the poetic Muses are there
they're telling him what to write uh
this this blazing figure comes in this
philosophy she's described as like
having absolutely blazing eyes or she's
she's she's able to pierce right through
him and she's got this this s of
ambiguous stature see sometimes she
looked like she was as big as a as a
human being and other times she was up
to the to the heavens very rich
symbolism and then other times her head
went through the heavens U and she says
basically who let these uh Shany C Mary
trul ask who let these theatrical Tarts
or poetic Horrors or whatever you want
to say in here to this man they have no
cure for his pain they only make it
worse and and and so she's basically
saying you know she's he's he's caught
in this and I think this is a really
interesting moment because we've all
been there right you know this moment
where you can't see out of your own a
depression uh you're you're you're in a
bad thought pattern or whatever you want
to call it you can't get out you can't
get get out and feeling sorry for
yourself and that makes thing and then
you feel passive and you the victim and
it's all so terrible and so she comes in
and
um and so it's very interesting her
first move is this kind of condemnation
of these poets who are just making
things worse it's a kind of feeling uh
sory for myself uh like Netflix show or
something and and she and she K she
kicks them out but it's worse than that
because it's in a pattern and it's like
a loop it's a loop and so she she kicks
them out but very interestingly she then
says this woman who has just banished
The Poets or the the muses she says
leave him to my uses to heal and make
whole so what she's suggesting is that
there's a different kind of of poetry
that isn't just sort of Phil story for
myself uh wo is me but but but but could
be salutary and and and transformative
and so um but then she she has uh she he
can't even recognize her this we we have
to skip through the symbolism it's
terrible to thing to do in a Jonathan
pedo podcast uh maybe we can revisit it
at some point but what that her she is
such a richly symbolic figure um he can
this the first few pages you could spend
hours on them but he can't recognize her
even though he studied with her so his
his vision is blurred with tears but
that's also metaphorical he can't access
he he can't recognize his surroundings
he doesn't know himself he can't
recognize her and there's this beautiful
moment she's wearing this dress that she
says she's woven
herself um what does that mean it's like
wisdoms represent what we can see wisdom
by is the work of wisdom itself
something like that yeah and uh but it's
torn H it's torn it's it's you know
marauding you it's like Bandits she he
says it's Event Event like all the the
many competing philosophical schools
have each taken a garment Taken part of
it they've ripped the stoics or the
Skeptics or the epicurian or whatever uh
but you know clearly what buthus is
after is that unitary you know what
brings all these together so what he
what she says is so this beautiful
moment she makes a fold in her dress
this kind of a sacramental moment and
she wipes the tears away from his eyes
so that that he can see her and
recognize her as the teacher of his
Youth and so there's a very beautiful
moment in which and I
think this is deep right I mean like the
first moment you can't you can't get
there you like it's a moment of it's an
act of Grace fundamentally it's an act
of the good towards us that gets us out
of frees us liberates us from our our
our our inescapable self kind of regard
and self-pity but then what happens is
it is just tough freaking love she's
like you know tell me what's wrong with
you basically and he goes on this long
diet tribe about oh I lost this I lost
that I was mistreated I've been accused
falsely of treason and now I'm here in
the prison and of course he's writing
all this but he's portraying himself as
just an absolute I have been and you
know let's take his word for it let's
assume he's justly his account of his
situation is fair and he is a victim of
these
terrible injustices and she and she said
and he says I've been I've been uh I've
been banished and she says to him and
this is such a pivot in the book she
says banished you
say a man's true Homeland if you are
banished from your true Homeland well
then I say you have banished yourself
because only you can remove yourself
from you know true self-possession in
the place that you belong and so his
retort is well hold on I've I've lost
all these things how could I be happy
and so the first part of the book I'm
going to move much more quickly here now
first part of the book is is a kind of
negative action she has to separate him
out from his attachments in the world
his attachment to money his attachment
to his position of power and his Fame
and all of that and she so she shows him
by and by you can certainly read read
your way through these beautiful
arguments and they're so powerful in
which she she says okay you know let's
take money for example you know is it
ever really yours what if the stock
market crashes you know what if what if
someone steals it away it's like and in
the argument of all these things same
with frame Fame well you could have your
reputation trashed H and then what you
know her argument is anything that can
be taken away from you is not really
yours so that's that's the first part of
the book and he go and he has to think
okay then well you know what is mine and
so she'll say well well what are you
really seeking in in those things that's
the next thing so let's say in wealth
maybe you're seeking security so she
shows that there's a spiritual good
that's really being sought in this thing
that that you think is the thing but can
be taken away from you so it can't be
what you're really after because you
wouldn't want a it wouldn't be a real
happiness if someone if it were
externally dependent it could just be
taken away so then she goes to show that
what the the you might say the actual
object is being s whether it's security
or or or or power in the sense of
ability to realize myself
my power to realize what I'm really up
seeking in the world that say it's not
external uh or or or or security or or
beauty or whatever the case may be and
so she shows through this argument that
there's a kind of unitary all these
things are connected they're not
separate they're actually you know the
thing that would really be be desirable
is
to to make you secure is also beautiful
uh is also self-sufficient and so on and
so she shows how each of these spiritual
Goods that are behind the material you
might say things are actually all
participating in in in in in in in a
single unified good and so then we come
to this problem that we were talking
about a minute ago which is that okay
well yeah that's it that's the thing uh
but then the problem is my seeking of
that in time and you know sometimes I'm
doing this and sometimes I'm doing that
they're all dividing this up and so the
very thing that I my the very thing I
want my approach to that thing is
preventing me from having that thing and
that's a very that's a very it's a very
uh it's a very uh deep moment and I
think it's important to take a step back
and reckon a bit with you know this as
the kind of problem of finitude itself
right you know
the the you
know how can any of our efforts you ever
amount to anything let's say you want to
love your your partner your wife your
husband your child you want to love them
like perfectly you want to this is like
even that it's like you know nothing but
failure you know it's like the the
efforts to be adequate even to this one
thing and
so there's this moment of prayer that
follows that in which they're turning
towards the highest good to help them
overcome that
problem and uh the remainder of the of
the of the book it gets in a sense the
problem becomes even more real even even
even sharper so let's say you're
starting out in this world of you know
you know Injustice and uh being robbed
of everything you had you
know uh in in a moment of suffering and
you know his complaint at the beginning
I should have said is is that there's no
order in the world because these things
would not be possible if there was order
in the world I would not be in this this
this position of
disenfranchised Injustice if there were
and and
so what she shows in this first half is
that there is order
because your actions this is an argument
that comes from Plato your actions are
their own reward so you know remember we
were saying how
if it's external like you know riches
well that can be taken away from you but
if if you uh what she shows is that it
within our actions the good or evil they
bring about is internal to them so if
you do something good in virtue you an
act of love that can't be taken away
from you it's it's what you are whereas
even if you're not caught if you do
something that degrades your soul that
degradation is internal you lie you
betray someone whatever that's so so
what she says is that uh is that is that
um uh actions have their own reward or
punishment present in them yeah the good
that you do that's the reward and it's
it's a it's the it's a reward in also in
the sense that you cannot it cannot be
taken away from you can't you can't be
stripped of that good because so and so
too in the negative side that and so so
what she shows is that in fact intrinsic
inaction is already this Justice of you
getting the reward of the punishment you
deserve because his claim at the
beginning is you know good people are
you know get punished and you know bad
people get rewarded and she's saying
well that may look that like what it is
externally but actually internally
that's not the case and it's a very deep
and Powerful because there is ultimately
there can be no happiness he argues
other than one that is internally
possessed so then the question is how do
you how do you possess that but the
second part of the book is very
interesting because you can see in a
sense and I think we all face this
okay we're living in what seems like a
disordered world and then the answer can
be well over Yonder there's a Unity that
we seek and that you can maybe in a
moment of kind of mysticism or something
uh approach uh but then very interesting
in the second half of the book The The
Prisoner buthus rearticulates the
initial problem at a higher you you
might say even more fundamental level
because he's what he wants
ultimately you might say what all human
beings in some sense I would argue want
is not simply an answer that is over
there because we're living in the world
of of the finite and the broken and the
particular he wants an answer that makes
sense here uh in in the midst of this
and so the the later part of the book
deals with this question of the relation
between let's say um
uh uh Time and Eternity of the finite
and the infinite and
uh in a difficult sort of theological
section at the end ultimately with the
relation between Free Will and
Providence or the you might say the
absolute unity and of of of the first
principle itself and and I think what's
so beautiful about the the the the
ending of this this book which I'm not
going to spoil for your uh for your
listeners what's so beautiful about the
ending of the book is that it's a bit
like the question of um of a ladder like
if you get to the top and you kick away
the ladder or you get to the top and you
learn that the top destroys the ladder
because it's all predetermined or
something was like wait a second what
what was my journey after all like what
was was that not real and so what I what
I think is going on in this beautiful
book and the way in which its wisdom is
put in the form of of poetry of images
of of of of beautiful rhetorical uh uh
turns is this really a work of you might
say pedagogy it's a work in which the
wisdom is being put in a way that is
adequate to the both the soul of the
reader in confusion and alienation on
the one hand and to the integral uh
wisdom that it is it is it is it is uh
conveying so the fundamental you might
say argument is one that moves from
alienation and this sense that the whole
world is disordered but that demands to
be able to
see uh an order within that to one that
leads him on a journey such that he can
see a deeper you might say spiritual
logic as governing the world but but
more just as
importantly
to come to see
himself the mechanisms and principles of
his own knowing of his own activities as
you might say in the image of or a
manifestation of that underlying uh
wisdom yeah and so in that way it's a
deeply incarnational approach it's not a
it's not a gnostic idea like you
proposed at the outset like the idea
that you know all of this is all
illusion all this is all nothing and
once you get to the mystical with the
one then you know all that other stuff
doesn't matter but rather this
formulation at all the levels of How
It's adapted to the the particular and I
think this brings us to you know the
reason why I wanted to talk to you
mostly in the first place which is that
in your book one of the arguments you
make is that the very structure of the
poems the very use of meter the very way
in which boethus you know structures the
the the the meter of the lines in the
text is an incarnation of his journey
moving from a kind of broken disunity
and uh and uh you know a kind of
confusion towards this deeper Unity uh
and that in some ways that one of the
reason why it has such an impact on
Western Civilization is that it is
paraliturgical or it is lurgical in the
sense that if someone goes on the
journey with Bia even reads aloud the
poems that that participation in the
Rhythm as as much as the ideas that he's
he's he's formulating rationally is
reordering the soul of the participant
towards the good that is aimed at in the
book so maybe you can break down that
argument because I was really fascinated
by you know the the proposition you can
talk a bit about how you came to that
and and and what that looks
like well what I
um so say a few things what I what I
discovered and I I hasten to
add like
the the acoustic super structure of this
book is
astonishing um and I sort of uncovered
this but it's bit like I don't know
falling into a ditch and finding a gold
treasure or something uh it's like it I
didn't I didn't make the treasure I just
I just sort of realized it was there and
uh effectively what I what I I I argue
is that the the these poems meters are
organized into a a beautiful sort of of
symmetrical and interwoven structure so
there's a you might say a uh an an an
ordering of the acoustic character of
the book that I suggest mediates Time
and Eternity and now this maybe sounds
like a difficult thought uh but what I
would want to maybe start with is is
that is it this the need for repetition
is absolutely fundamental to our need or
to our ability to know to know anything
so let's just to give a good simple
example you know you can't so much as
recognize um and and memory let me say
memory and repetition are absolutely
fundamentally uh uh uh connected so so
you couldn't so much as uh you can't
recognize uh you couldn't so much as
recognize yourself in the mirror or or
your your front door or your mom or
whatever without without memory right
because it's memory that allows you to
to recognize in the present this as
something that you already you already
know and so so um so memory is
necessary to see a repetition but
repetition is necessary uh because
without it there's no there's nothing
stable at all so imag imagine uh imagine
you know just like being in a fire hose
you know life is a fire hose it's just
coming at you there's no interpretation
of anything it's just you know you don't
even know it's water right because it's
just that's you know that that's the
kind of
overwhelming flux of movement and change
you total nothing but change let's put
it that that way and you know life feels
that way sometimes right I mean that so
you can look at this let's just start in
the most stable way I mean in the most
in the in in the in the simplest way
let's say you know we've all been around
babies you know uh most of us anyway
when they're you know early on when
they're born and you know they they look
up at their at their hand and and they
don't even know that's their hand yeah
right like they have no idea it's just
they're not yet conscious of of that
fact and so the question is how do you
move from that moment as a as a child as
an infant that can't even recognize its
mother or its own like limbs to one that
knows oh this is me and that's that's my
mother and what I what what I'm arguing
is that it's the it's repetition it's
seeing this again and again and again
that that stabilizes imagine yourself as
an infant it's just everything moving
around and to us like you the world is
stable it's like no there's the door to
the front house and that's Mom and you
know there's the fireplace and you know
there's the there's the the the the
painting on the wall or whatever and
here are the people I see them all but
the question what I'm trying to draw out
here is how do you get there to the
point where that you can interp that
world versus where the baby starts but I
don't want to put ourselves in the
baby's position in a sense of to where
we actually are right because the
question
is how do
you you can only
interpret the movement of uh of the
World Around You by stabilizing it by by
having a frame that locates it such that
you can see this particularity within a
pattern whether it's a person uh this
I'm giving examples of physical things
but as you go deeper you realize there
are deeper patterns that govern those
things
and so my argument fundamentally is
that we need recurrence of rep we need
to expose ourselves to to to recurrence
or repetition in order to be shaped in
such a way such that our memories are
able to interpret and understand the
world around us and so we see this you
know we see this you know all the time
with you know the the cycle of day and
night you know imagine we were just
living in one endless day and there was
no sun coming up and down imagine there
was no cycle of of of seasons of course
if you live at the equator that is in
fact what what you have but for most of
us we're living in a in a movement
through time in which there are these
cycles and
so and we we do this at home we have
rituals in the morning and we have
rituals in the evening and we have
rituals at you know Christmas time or
religious holidays and so on we have
Civic liturgies in Canada remembrance
days is is
historically an import an important
moment in America in the United States
Thanksgiving is an important such day
and what those are are rhythms of a
certain kind of practice through which
We Gather our ourselves and our
experience in order to understand it so
you pause on
Thanksgiving and you you you might say
you gather up all of the last that has
happened since you've last done that in
a moment that allows you to to to
understand yourself in relation to say
gratitude yeah but I would say at a at a
at a more fundamental level or at a very
fundamental level this is the case with
all of us all the time but I'll add just
one one one more thing and that is
that there's a sense in
which you think about the in
you can't recognize something that isn't
part of a
repetition that you recognize yeah and
so we are in a certain sense nothing but
the memories that we hold that allow us
to interpret the world and that's why
the shaping of our memories is so
important because it's what enables us
to to see to see the world around us and
so in some sense that's why you might
say the study of history or the forming
of ourselves in relation to fundamental
patterns otherwise you end up being like
the infant who doesn't even know that's
your mother you can't you can't see
what's in front of you the world is is
is an unstable
flux until you internalize its patterns
such that you can see them outside of
you yeah and I I think that before we
get deeper into the boethus idea you
know it's important for people to
understand that in that's why Plato you
know almost joins together the idea of
memory and knowledge that is to know
something is to remember it and you
know we can find different ways of
formulating formulating that
metaphysically you know obviously Plato
had a this kind of reincarnation model
where where where the sense that you're
remembering you know ancient lives and
that is what making is making you
participate in it and you know as humans
now we can we don't need a reincarnation
model to understand that even
biologically we understand that we are
the ascendance of of patterns that have
re-embodied themselves over and over and
over and we part and it's when we when
we know something means we're tapping
into that at the low level we could also
formulate it vertically and understand
that when we know something we are
connecting to a cosmic memory we're
connecting to a cosmic pattern of
repetition and of truth that
instantiates itself to the world and we
kind of remembered that way so even
whether you look at it as biological or
whether you look at it vertically
towards these idea that there are these
kind of uh Transcendent Cosmic patterns
we can understand how knowledge is
memory it it and it's represented that
way in the Bible by the way constantly
you know you could we could call it
aention in memory right aention and
memory as as kind of two faces of the
same thing um the idea that God
remembers man that man remembers God we
see that in the story of Noah we see
that in the story of Jonah we see it ly
in the you know and when we you know
even when we talk about the way in which
we participate in the people that came
before us we formulate that as memory
why do we we have memorials we talk when
someone dies in the Orthodox tradition
we say memory Eternal and that their
memory be Eternal but it it is it's not
just a a vague sentimentality it's a
mode of participation right it's a mode
of I'm connecting to those ancient lives
and I'm a continuation a reod ment of
the good that they these people did in
our lives today um and so I think it for
people just to understand that that that
this isn't just a kind of artistic
artistic uh fancy to talk about these
questions of pattern and memory but they
really are really the way that in which
we engage with with the way in which we
recognize the world to exist you know
just full stop um yeah and there's a way
in which the like if you imagine you
know life in the fire hose
and in some sense you know uh
we're in this time in history we're all
way too much in the fire hose in a sense
right and but if you if you imagine you
know by metaphor the infant who can't
recognize anything um
uh as a kind of metaphor for how
uh many of us certainly myself you know
are living far too much of the time uh
the question is well what is the
alternative to that and what is it that
allows anything to become stable so that
you're you're you're you're not simply
like if you imagine you know every day
living every day different with
completely different patterns completely
different people completely different
place you you you would know nothing at
all right you're just you're just in
this in this constant sea of change and
what I think is is is so interesting is
that is that you know
these you know what is going on in a
moment in which you know you step
outside of that and you sort of
understand oh that moment and this
moment and this moment those are all
those are all in me and connected and
understood and you know I think it's
often interesting to talk about for
example
uh people often in experience of nature
have this sense which you know they they
they move beyond the particular into
something that gathers the particular
often in music or art and you're
listening to I don't know Bach is often
very famously brought up in these
connections because of the way that his
music
has such an astonishing integration of
patterns moving through time that you
can you can track with and so what I'm
wanting to say most fundamentally is
that there is
no
you self-consciousness itself like any
knowledge of anything is a
stabilization uh that is taking us
outside of the immediate into something
that is
transhistorical right so the moment that
you you know let's say you know you you
understand yourself to be the same
person that you were that the same
person as you were when you were a kid
you know that you haven't changed and
grow grown up and so on but you see a
continuity you're like oh no you
remember that and now and so in that
moment in our in ourselves what we have
in our in our memories is a way of
making the past present now and so
memory is by definition and of course
the present doesn't really exist right
because as soon as you're aware of it
it's already happened it's like you know
that it's like perception you know the
thing by the time you see it it's
already in the past you know even just a
micr or whatever but it's already
happened and so what I'm trying to
suggest is that is that Ian it sounds
very huant and difficult when you talk
about the relation between Time and
Eternity but this is really the the the
nature of of of life right is that
that you you can be you can be lost in
flux and
movement or you can the answer to that
is to find some longer continuity
that you by definition has already taken
you outside of
time but then the question is well what
does that have to do with my movement
through the world in time and so in some
sense that's precisely what patterns
give us is they give us ways of
stabilizing ourselves in our movement
Through Time such that we're able to see
in the moment the Eternal
or open the moment becomes
something that reveals a deeper
stability yeah and so it's interesting
like one of the arguments that you make
very simply in the book that I found
really powerful is that you talk about
how the patterning of the words and the
patterning of the uh you know the
creation of these the these frames they
are nemonic in the sense that they help
you remember right and people talk about
that sometimes too when they say that
one of the reasons why monks would chant
the Psalms or that rabbis would chant
the Psalms is so because by you doing
this kind of pattern language uh it's
easier to remember the text but there's
also a deeper sense in which it's
demonic right is in the sense that it's
connecting you to the pattern of reality
itself it's making you remember that it
is through this pattern existence that
anything that everything that we
participate in comes to find any
cohesion whatsoever right the fact that
you exist is pneumonic right the fact
that that because you're able to connect
all these different ele elements
together towards knowing that like you
said the 5-year-old version of Stephen
and you in in a in a very mysterious way
is the same being that is continuing on
with the same the same pattern um yeah
and I just thought that was really
interesting because maybe can go bit a a
little bit into that into you know
because the this is to me the deeper
understanding of musicality and also the
deeper understanding of you know when we
we I remember when I was in school but
people talked about uh the idea of The
Music of the Spheres and how it's kind
of this kind of ridiculous uh mythology
right the idea that the Spheres make
music and that we we don't hear it
anymore but that is the deepest part of
that which is that the Music of the
Spheres or even the ancient study of
Music wasn't just the ancient study of
how to make entertainment music for for
a party but really how to live in the
patterns like really what liturgy is and
this is what this is there in BO himself
as well in his text yeah so I mean let's
let's just uh let's put it this way that
that
um two things
first the the
uh this whole kind of the art of memory
the the we talk about ne ne the
neonic
is you know it's pretty amazing first of
all what you what what a human mind can
remember and you as you know Plato and
the fedis is worried about our losing
our memories when we start writing
things down and you know that's of
course exactly what happens we see that
with the Internet it's not what you know
it's where to find it and all this kind
of nonsense but it's also true that it
that's what happens is you know when you
don't need to you know you you lose that
and so it's actually a very scary thing
to think about how much less we have in
us to understand the world right because
we think we can just find it all we
don't even know what what to look for
right and so what I what I want to say
is first of all that the the human mind
is an amazing thing from the point of
view of of memory and if you look into
the medievals and even today their
memory competitions people who think
they have bad memories are then capable
of astonishing Feats right but the the
the the deeper Point H is is what that
is doing in terms of formation and so uh
it's interesting that when we have in
English for example we have in the first
place we would say in the second place
and this is a this is a hold over from
from from the art you might say the art
of memory in the Middle Ages when you
would if you were trying to remember
something you would say okay well let's
say the maybe the houses on my street or
the the uh the rooms in my house and you
you say okay I'm going to put this thing
that I want to remember in the first
room and you you picture it there and
I'm put this thing in the second room
and and so on and that this is sort a
short version of how the art of memory
works but I want to make a much deeper
point which is that
like
you in some some sense you can only
understand that which you have the
places to put things you can only put
things in places you have to put them is
what I'm trying to say and so what does
that mean well Aristotle has this this
uh uh wonderful uh account of of of
habit and you know today we like to
think well you know I did all these bad
things but I'm not really that doesn't
really Define me that's not really what
I am and well Aristotle would say no you
are you are what you've what you what
you what you've done and and habits are
very powerful right because you know
they're they're they're they're they're
like an unconscious memory you repeat it
and you did it again and again and again
and then it's just what you are like you
know I give the example sometimes that
in the home that that my family lived in
for many years at one point they moved
the cutlery drawer for the silverware
from one part of the kitchen to the
other and it was after I'd gone to
college and every time I come back I
would always be going there right
because it but but you can you can put
that uh uh you can take that example and
realize that that that we form ourselves
by the things we do and if you're formed
in I don't
know listening to a lot of negativity
and anger and frustration and ranker on
the internet like that's what you become
in a profound sense right that's where
that's the truth of Plato's line right
is that you
you you the kind of vision we
bring is to the world the form of
perceiving limits what we're able to see
in it and so the whole question of habit
is so important for example if you were
a parent you know you think about well
you could you know teach your child to
you don't know to have no self-control
and and and and you know be completely
you dominated by his or her emotions by
rewarding certain behavior and and so on
and then what what the world that that
child is able to see is completely
constrained by the habits they have
taken on the person they can become is
limited by the fact that they're they
they have habits that prevent a deeper
form of seeing in the world whereas if
you you know is the wonderful line in
the scripture says you know if you set
your mind on things
above such that you have habits of
recollection such that you're able to
see and perceive deeper pattern deeper
patterns and you might say become more
and more adequate to those patterns
whether it's of you
know love or patience or humility or or
whatever then that's what you're able to
find in the world but it's not as if you
can
access in the world that which you don't
already have the way of being able to
see and that's why I give the language
of the the image of the infant who who
is who is lost to even
seeing his or her own hands in the world
now because we have the categories of
Consciousness like it's not as if we're
a blank slate the infant is innately
able to recognize these patterns because
the human Mind Is Made in such a way as
to be able to perceive them and if it
weren't then it wouldn't be able to able
to see them but the the point
fundamentally is
that everything is at stake in the
habits we develop and the patterns we
expose ourselves to because it is what
we will be able to see in the world yeah
and I think that's such a everybody can
find examples in themselves or in other
people where they've noticed that you
know let's say someone
who who is not trustworthy or someone
who tries to trick people people tries
to get things will their world will get
built that way and then at some point
they'll find themselves in a situation
where they're also surrounded by people
that you can't trust that you're
surrounded by people that they shouldn't
trust but it's and and the opposite is
true is
that you know this is something that you
can see in Christ's word the idea of of
saying that if you judge not right lest
you be judged that is that if you if you
practice the good then all of a sudden
you will start to see goodness in the
world that because the world has
multiplicity and variance and that and
and there's even a powerful way in which
if you learn to live in the good and see
the good you can actually call the good
out of others right you can actually and
you you know that because sometimes you
realize that when you're with certain
people you're the best version of
yourself and then when you you're with
other people you kind of become the
worst version of yourself in all in all
kinds of ways and that this is what what
you're trying to bring about is that the
patterning of existence has a deep
effect on on who you are and who you
remember yourself to be because we do
have the potential of being of change
like of changing that's that's what
humans are we can be you know all kinds
of different things and that can happen
at at any time in our life but if we
have these deep patterns of virtue but
also deep patterns of habit in the
simple sense you know like eating three
meals a day sleep sing certain amount of
hours you know and I see it in my life
because I I have a you know I have this
weird I have a kind of creative Bend to
myself and I can see myself sometimes
fall into like not you not sleeping not
eating well not and then things start to
shake around me like in every way like
not just in terms of my habit but also
in terms of the way I treat others the
way I see the world the way I interpret
the way other people treat me then it
starts to shake but you know maybe you
can bring us through a little bit how it
is that bothus does it in his text like
what is it that he brings you to through
really you without going into the
details about the different meters of
the poems but the basic image of how he
takes the reader the participant in his
text through a kind of poetic
transformation towards towards the
highest
good sure I'd be I'd be I'd be happy to
to to to try and say a few things about
that I've just been sort of meditating
on I think what you're saying is
very very very very very deep I mean the
way that I mean what is
the see we tend to think that the way we
feel about the world is how the world is
right but it's actually no no no no
that's that's exactly that's where Plato
starts is saying no um you can your the
way you you might say feel about the
world is determining what you're able to
see in it that's what's going on it's
nothing you might say to do with the
world in a sense uh and so question is
well how do you do have a vision that's
more and more adequate to seeing what's
really there and that's that's you might
say the whole question of the spiritual
intellectual life that's a whole
question of parenting or teaching or
whatever how do you how do you shape
yourself or others into a way that you
can see what's really there and you
think about the difference between
someone who's you know you know always
complaining or woe is me or whatever or
or always busy and running onto the next
thing as sometimes I am often I am or
someone who is I don't know what is what
is it like to be with someone that
sees you when you when you're in their
presence you think gosh I just feel
better I feel like I'm I'm I'm seeing
I'm I'm I'm closer to what I'm meant to
be what is going on with someone who I
knew I've known a few people like this
who very presence was able to mediate a
deeper sense of the world a true and
More Beautiful sense of the world um now
now in terms of BU is I'll just give a
couple of
examples
um The Poetry Works in different ways
one way it works is you know those of
you who you know read poetry you know
that you know the way the Rhythm works
is part of the way the message is
conveyed the message is is encoded in
that sense partly in the in the in the
in the in the way in which the it sounds
you know um you get these wonderful
rhythms I I give example you know
towards the night before Christmas and
all through the house not a creature was
stirring not even a mouse and that that
and that kind of Rhythm you have this
sort of way of you know you're you're
it's it's loing you in it's a beautiful
uh repeated pattern again and again um
uh but you can also have you can also
have uh rhythms that are that are
jarring uh that that are they surprising
or or or or or unexpected of course
that's what Jazz often of often does and
so so one level at which the the the
poetry works is it's it's it's simply
manifesting you might say the the the
truth or the idea that is present in the
poem
so for example there's a there's a
lovely lyrical me meter Dum D Dum D dum
dum d d Dum D Dum D Dum that that in
this this it's called a glycon but
what's beautiful in that is that he uses
it in early on to describe the the
stability of the seasons and and and the
the the consistency of these changes in
nature and so he's using this wonderful
lyric she's using it I should say lady
philosophy philosophy is using it as a
way of con she's trying to settle him
down and speak a kind of stability to
him in his instability and she does this
so I mean so wonderful the way she does
this both by giving him images that his
mind can say oh yeah I know those
patterns in nature I I've seen I've seen
I've seen seen that but also putting it
in a way so that it's sonically
acoustically stabilizing and lyrical
it's like you know we all know with a
with an infant you know what do you do
with an infant that's that's that's you
know upset and crying and so on you know
tap tap tap tap tap tap tap tap tap tap
right you you you and then you know you
can music can do the same thing but you
at the very most basic level the rocking
is a pattern that stabilizes the child
so that's one sense and then there there
are other poems where where she's
talking about the instability
of Fortune for example and it'll be like
Dump Dump Dump you know it will be it
will be she'll he she'll use an unstable
meter to convey the instability so
that's one level but then what's amazing
is that is that H is that some of these
meters they occur later on and then the
question is well what's going on there
is it the same is it just well okay well
we figured it out last time and it was
inst it was lyrical and stable or it was
instable but actually what I what I what
I think is is is is going on is the way
in which the
later uses of the meters are doing
something Redemptive relative to uh the
that you might say the problems or
issues or matters that were raised in
the in the first time time time around
so you know there's there's one in in in
which um the instability of a meter that
was used to describe the you know the
you contingency or Fortuna you know the
instability of of the world you know all
its unknowns she actually uses to show
how that instability is comprehended by
a deeper pattern so the way I
um I think this is so beautiful Jonathan
because
um because there's a there's a deep
sense in which healing has to take place
at the sight of the wound right like if
if you've had this kind of experience or
that and you've been shaped or damaged
or or broken
there's a sense you know that's where
the healing has to be and so I think one
thing that's going on in in the in the
poem is she's she's she's redeeming
these broken Moments by uh through this
you might say acoustic recollection of
an earlier moment to give you might say
the answer to the
problem or the pain that was in the
first instance and so it's it's a way of
you might say redeeming by show by
recollecting uh and of course
psychologists use this this this uh all
the time but then there's a third level
and that is that is I think that as as
you look at the poem as an acoustic
struct the the poems of the book as an
acoustic structure and in readers who
are interested can see uh pattern this
out in color uh at the the back of of
the book you've got to get the paperback
though because the hard cover was
printed in black and white and it's much
harder to see but in the paperback you
can see these unbelievably intricate
patterns of the poems and so what I'm
I'm arguing is that is that the whole
acoustic structure of the Poetry has an
interwoven uh uh uh pattern that means
that any point of it is part of it's
like what you say about fractalization
right any point of it is integrated
within a larger pattern and so um in
fact I maybe maybe uh share two things
quickly and one is that
um you know I think we this is how
memory works right like uh I give the
example in the book that where I grew up
I love wild roses and I've all these you
know these the first instance you you
see the rose wow that's that smells good
and it's kind of a memory on its own but
then the longer you go through life like
that well oh that reminds me of that
place that I used to go in the summer
and with that person and then it it it
it it it's a reminder of childhood and
it's a rem and so you start seeing that
you smell the rose again and you're like
whoa that has all these deep forms of
pattern that it brings up to you maybe
it's a it's it's reminding you of loss
or of happiness or and so all of these
things become collected precisely
because the patterns are moving through
different moments in time and and you
know I I
you know I my grandmother died a few
years ago and but I know you know if
someone was wearing her perfume it was
very distinctive to her that would bring
back all of my memories of my my grandm
so there's a there's this sense in which
one thing we want to do is to scaffold
into life the patterns that enable us to
gather up our past as present in a way
that it can be comprehended and then and
then um uh the other thing I say is that
as you say if you look in the pend of my
book you see all these really
complicated patterns and I had a moment
when I was writing this that I thought I
mean really like is is it really there
like this thing pretty complicated
and um and I was uh my brother was
living in rural Vermont my wife was away
and my brother had come to visit uh in
the the sort Hills of Vermont and
Mountain
Ridge and I had taken him to the bus
station and I was driving back uh and
and uh uh so this woman hitchiking the
side of the road uh and uh well of
course that's why you hit shik side of
the road but anyway she's standing the
side of the road and she's she's she's
clearly upset she's got a garbage bag
with all sort of her possessions and I
uh
I I stopped and you know before I could
start heard even stopped she was she was
already kind of threw her things in the
back and got in and she was very upset
uh she was a you know woman in very
challenging circumstances and as I got
to know her where she was going was
about 45 minutes away and I was not too
too far from where I was I was going and
we got into a a conversation about her
and she had a very sad sort of life
story multigenerational dysfunction and
drug abuse and children in prison and it
was it was very very very sad and uh uh
she had been crying and I I don't know
what had happened she had sort immediate
crisis where she couldn't stay where she
was and had to go somewhere else and so
um her things in the garbage bag and uh
uh uh her name was
constant uh I I think she may have been
I don't know if she maybe she was an
angel maybe she was as I as I tell this
story it just seems to be unbelievable
her name her name was constants right
yeah but anyway so she was very upset
and I I asked her I was trying to you
know
as we try to do for people it's like
what philosophy does for bu is I was
trying to calm her I was trying to help
her find you know ReDiscover
herself and uh so I asked her you know
what do you what do you like to do and
uh she said oh I said I love to knit and
I said really well well tell me tell me
tell me about it um and she said well
you know when I'm when I'm knitting he
said why do you like knitting she said
well when I'm knitting she said I I Lose
Myself in the pattern and and I said you
know here I was working on these
patterns and things about the
recollection self-possession and I mean
she meant lose herself in the sense of
finding herself he was connecting with
something something something something
more permanent and and I said uh well
you know you knitting anything now and
and she said yeah I am I'm knitting this
this this blanket for my daughter and
and I said tell me about it and she said
well it's it's pretty complicated and I
said well I'd love to hear about it and
she said okay well there's there's 12
sections and each of the sections has
six colors and the patterns uh the
colors Mo uh change in these patterns in
each section and then they relate and I
was
like holy smokes like this is
unbelievable she this woman is telling
me a an account and she got all this in
her head and she in the back it's in
this bag in the back do you want me to
show it to you and so here I had this
beautiful kind of revelation of this you
know woman in in very difficult
circumstances who was showing me like in
her profound way the truth of what was
happening what I had sort of discovered
in some sense in buthus that that you
know you think it's complicated you know
it is life is complicated Bach is
complicated yeah but it's
complicated it's very
complication it's it's
interwovenness is what enables it to
stabilize and gather things into a
pattern and so I came of course to think
that these patterns really were not only
really were there they can be there
knitting they could probably be there in
bathus exactly so uh it's to thanks to
constants that uh you might say in a
sense I came to see how how much we
need to expose
ourselves to
patterns through which we can uncover
and discover ourselves yeah I mean it's
such a great Insight that you have
because if you can imagine the woman uh
knitting you know and you know I imagine
at first she's counting right she's
actually counting she's like one two
three da d da and at some point she
probably also stops counting where it
becomes like when you're dancing and
you're not thinking about it and you're
just you're just doing a walls and
you're not thinking about where you're
putting your feet and kind of enter into
that Rhythm and to what extent like you
said it it transports us into something
that is beyond us you know that is when
we can kind of understand the power of
of poetry its relationship to something
like liturgy in the strict Christian
sense but also liturgy in the broader
sense which is these patterns whether it
is family meals whether it is you know
even the simple patterns of how you
organize your day and how you kind of
set things up um that these are that all
of this is connected to how humans Find
meaning you know it's very powerful
definitely wow and so thanks Stephen I
would say everybody if if if there's
someone here now that hasn't read the
consolation of philosophy and you you're
not going to read it like I you're a
hopeless person at this point like it is
an astounding text one of the
foundational text of of of Western
civilization and also check out
Stephen's book it's called the
consolation of
buus uh as poetic liturgy it's very it's
a it's a technical book but the art
argument is very powerful and it's worth
looking into especially if you're
interested in the question of patterns
and how patterns affect us today and so
Stephen thanks for everything you do you
know everybody who who doesn't know
about rosson college it is worth looking
into rosson college it is a seed of Hope
in this time I was able to uh to
participate in a trip with uh with
Stephen and the some of the people
around rosson College was astounded at
what it is that it's possible to do
today uh and it does give us hope in a
moment where we feel like everything's
breaking down uh thanks for what you're
doing Stephen it's truly appreciated
well thank you Jonathan it's a great
privilege to have this conversation uh
to be on your podcast and your
friendship has been a a great gift to me
I I'll only say in conclusion that to
those who haven't read
buus just remember that if you're ever
in a really a difficult circumstance um
that that book is is is uh is there is
there for you I I once uh a friend of
mine I was uh once met a friend of mine
at a at a meeting it was a board meeting
in Boston and she had had cancer uh and
I thought it had gone away but it had
come back and uh it was very sad uh uh
anyway I didn't know what to do and I
went into the bookstore and uh there was
a bookstore there and I bought herook I
I think I just have to give this woman a
copy of beus and uh she wrote to me a
few weeks later saying that you know
words had never been so meaningful to
her and uh so I I I say that because uh
it might be that this is a book that can
u in a time that you really need it you
can turn to it yeah all right thanks
Stephen and we'll talk soon as well
we'll see each other possibly for uh the
second part of our uh of our team of
Bible interpreters we're hoping to see
that happen for those who are hoping
that that will it seems like it might so
that would be wonderful thank you
Jonathan it's a real pleasure bye for
now thanks